so if you don't want to get burned look
for people who have the capacity to grow
themselves no don't do that
apparently things you
my reaction series today I am going to
be reacting to PO math again guys this
guy deserves to have a million
subscribers on YouTube literally this
guy is so funny so he does basically
drawings to depict what is going on in
the dating market and he really responds
and basically transcribes womanies the
things we say and what we mean by them
because us chicks we just we don't even
know what we're saying we don't even
ourselves know how to articulate what we
mean so we need guys to come in and
communicate for us how funny is that so
today I'm reacting to a video on my
whole math called mostly ho let's bring
it up I love honest women she's she's
giving away the whole game she says that
if if a girl went through a hoe phase
she's probably just a hoe and I'm rating
that mostly ho I use this diagram you
can download it on my you know what's
funny my dad one my dad is just one of
those really wise he's a really Wise Guy
growing up my dad would just give me
like these little nuggets of wisdom that
really just honestly stuck with me and
they just stick with me for life and you
know one time I was dating a guy my dad
didn't really like because women right
it's like I didn't listen shocking and I
asked him I was like Dad do you think
people change and he just he looks at me
and he says you know people do change
they get worse over time typically so
whatever trait you see now just expect
it to be worse in 10 years and the older
I get now are there exceptions that
change yet but in general people in life
tend to get fatter they tend to get
dumber and they don't tend to improve
themselves over time and especially like
us women like if we're resentful at 20.
at 40 we're like ultimate Karen [__]
so you know when this woman is saying
she had a whole phase
um yeah I mean more likely than not I
want to see what he says but I'd say
more likely than not yeah let's see
let's see and the other day I pointed
out there was a video of a girl who
wanted to keep her boyfriend and her
side guy loyal and I pointed out that
this is most like a mental limitation
and not and it when you're an adult very
difficult row at these levels so I I
evaluated her as not fixable with
behaviors like that or like this you can
tell people what to change can't make
them want I'm gonna tell you a little
story about a time that I stayed at a
Motel 6 because I love talking about
myself so first of all I I lost a lot of
trust for women when my body count
started to rise and it's been kind of
this kind of a deep-seated behavior like
a hoe face so one time I was traveling
through the Pacific Northwest I was
staying at a Motel 6 because I'm poor
please send money and I met a girl who
was right about the the minimum of what
I would settle for what I would marry or
move in with if she had a great
personality I think I was here and she
was there so this girl chased me out of
the lobby and back towards my room and
struck up a conversation with me and
gave me a palm reading and it was really
obvious that she wanted me to make a
move and I thought about how bad this
had been for me and and I said no I said
thank you but I don't think it's good
for me and that's the first time that I
ever said no something that was so easy
I just didn't want this to go any lower
and here's the thing again I'm amazing I
am such I'm so cool I have done so much
I have changed myself so much in my
adult life this is not a comprehensive
list but I don't I don't want to point
out Everest it'll narrow down who I am
here's the thing if you if you really
want to find out whether this is true
about somebody you have to look at can
they can they and have they done things
like this in their life because there
are there are visible things and there
are invisible things about people or
less visible the visible part is that
this guy is five foot and the invisible
part is that he has a great sense of
humor and he's very smart and whether
her whole phase was a phase or whether
she's just stuck there is people have
been asking me for a list of ways to
tell who's more likely to cheat and and
one of them is is if she doesn't change
as a person
um have you ever have you ever seen her
you know stop a bat have you ever seen
her develop and and if so was it
deliberate so if if someone that you're
trying to evaluate if they you know
can't quit smoking or they won't lose
weight or they stay in a job that's bad
for them and and that person had a hoe
phase it probably isn't a face doing
this is hard she was very tempting
basically we're talking someone who I
might put about here who was offering me
this it was a slam dunk and I said no I
didn't want to feel any more of this so
if you don't want to get burned look for
people who have the capacity to grow
themselves anyway I was about to say my
dad would say no don't do that
my dad I'm just I hear sometimes it's so
funny that's like the thing about us
chicks like you kind of have to have
like your dad in the back of your head
because otherwise we just go like nutty
and crazy
um you know or you know a guy male
figure whatever it is because it's like
I'll hear things and even though my dad
isn't like there like I hear him and I
don't know how to describe it but I like
I hear what he would say and he would
say something like don't count on it
because my dad my dad always told me
growing up he said Don't expect things
from anyone and he's like if I if I hire
someone I expect them to be terrible and
that way they can only exceed your
expectations so he just told me in life
expect nothing from nobody and then the
people and he's like maybe and it's
funny because I don't think anyone
around my dad would know he like views
it like this uh but I realized I'm like
I think spite happens when you have high
expectations and that somebody is like
low right and I was thinking so my dad
just keeps his expectations low and then
he's always happy it's like wow they did
anything but it's funny because my dad
yeah he would just say not likely I I
agree with that because I also employ a
similar tactic but like when I'm working
with people I always over no under
promise and over deliver so if like
maybe I'm supposed to deliver something
in like I'll tell the person and do this
in like 5
yeah that's a really great tactic I'm
gonna suggest it to to who see city name
I'm gonna suggest it to Blessings sorry
blessing
row themselves it's pretty rare to be
honest so you know the video was right
wow that's a great way hold on pretty
rare to be honest so you know yeah right
but only most yeah I thought that was
great phenomenal actually this guy I
love I'm a visual learner so the more
visual aids I really do I feel like I
thrive in this environment uh that's why
I'm always doing the Whiteboard videos
you know but guys go go subscribe to
home math um and let me know if there's
any videos you want to see me react to
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel I'll talk to
you next time